i don't think there's a risk at all i
mean i have strived throughout this
process to build a cross-party consensus
on ukraine and you know i've been very
lucky that i've been supported by
everyone from the snp the labour party
the leader of the labour party and the
liberal democrats in our policy towards
ukraine and i think that is going from
strength to strength there's not a week
that goes by where i either don't reach
out to them or talk to those parties but
also that we agree that it is important
to continue the effort to support
ukraine as it strives to defend itself
from this awful illegal invasion but
given that the that
ukraine regards the uk with such high
esteem and there's that personal bond
between president zolensky and boris
johnson
president zlinski must be looking at
london and seeing what's happening and
wondering what's happening to his key
ally what can you say to reassure them
well i think he knows because he's been
visited by a range of parliamentarians
and as has my uh counterpart the defence
minister that britain is full square
behind them and you know the assistance
ukraine we give is not just one person
you know we're not me not the prime
minister it's the whole effort actions
matter and all of this and you know
while the prime minister will be
incredibly sad to leave this post he has
led from the front on ukraine as he had
on covid and obviously brexit and i
think that isn't lost on many people but
the whole of the political system the
head of the general election not to cut
the british army and not cut the british
forces any shape or form do you think
the next prime minister would need to
make a similar commitment on uh
i i think the next prime minister uh
needs to make sure they commit to
investing in defence people can argue
about how that investment went but this
prime minister was the first prime
minister in generation to actually
reverse taking money out of defence and
putting it into investment the record 24
billion pounds has gone into defense
over for a four-year period and that's
the first time mostly in most people's
generation of a proper return to
investment until then from 1991 and the
options for change when i was serving
chancellor after chancellor after
chancellor took a peace dividend problem
is he kept taking it when the world got
more dangerous prime minister reversed
that i'll look to whoever is the next
prime minister to make sure they
continue to invest in our defence